even if you think of you know the
cameras in the store there's a lot of
water data okay for traffic there okay
how long they said that why did they
spend so were they confused or are they
interested in the products we have no
idea so asking the consumer actually
having the voice of the consumer while
they're in a store or while they're in
the home
not just let you observe them but also
let you understand their thought be
because they're underrated as they speak
or they're unboxing as they're cooking
or cleaning they're kind of talking
about their experience and they feel get
a blend of observing and talking and
sometimes those don't match right it
could be interesting that sometimes
people think they're doing something a
certain way but when you see it it's
actually very different but it's great
to have both those those data points and
then be able to make much more sense i
think not only right there people have
you know big data has been around for a
while there's a lot of what data that's
the issue i think is there's a lot of
what data there's not enough why data we
are focused on the why part of that data
right and so that's really where we
think there is you know in the past
years ago uh when you did qualitative
type of work you're doing in a very
small scale so you're kind of getting
quick feedback from a few sets a few
consumers and then you're really using
survey-based mechanisms to kind of get
those you know larger like validated
insights with a large group of people
but now thanks to technology now ai can
really help you know understand and
distill you know unstructured data much
faster and easier that's going to really
allow you to get and have conversations
at scale have you know observational
behavior kind of collected and analyzed
at scale and those kinds of insights get
much more depth um and therefore there's
much more insight that you're getting
out of it versus a closed-ended survey
that only gives you that much depth you
know it gives you a lot of scale and you
know uh validation but doesn't give you
enough depth and that's why you know if
you think about the the launch that it's
interesting depending on the source you
go to it's anywhere between 45 to 85
of cvg new cbg products fail
um and we believe the reason for that is
today the way they do it is very much
just survey-based concept-based data not
doing enough of usage tests for stuff
and they're also not doing enough of
that why an observation they're doing
much more conceptual survey based okay
people love this it should be successful
and really that is not enough at all and
so giving them both those sides of the
fence at scale is what we believe is
going to change those figures and allow
much more successful uh
perks so since we are you know tech
platform it's something that we have
basically you know we've made it such
that they can come and they can use it
very very much themselves so we don't
really need to provide much consultation
we do of course help you know with
designing things especially with the new
client who hasn't kind of worked with
these kinds of methodologies before so
we can guide them but there are many
clients already that you know kind of
know how to get the best value out of
this and clients also that are forward
thinking that say hey do you have this
so do you have that and sometimes you do
sometimes you don't when we don't we
listen very closely because then we know
okay this is what the market's asking
for and we're constantly building we're
pushing new product out every week twice
a week actually so it's something that
you know we're always staying ahead of
the game listening to customers and what
they want especially the ones that are
headed again and then of course for
those that are kind of just you know
more older school kind of coming into
this of course uh you have to have a
little bit of a heavier hand uh you know
guiding them but um you know it's been
it's been uh straightforward to do so
far
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
20-minute leaders is a proud supporter
of make-a-wish israel and tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret core adventures j ventures
riverside fm
fusion vc
birthright excel j impact leap google
for startups and hippo and in media
partnership with ctec
hello and welcome to another episode of
20 minute leaders this episode is with
nihal advani product and marketing
expert and the founder and ceo of
qualcites nihal combined his
entrepreneurial spirit and interest in
seeing and understanding the world by
launching qualsites an immersive
consumer insights platform that helps
companies understand human behavior
authentically and efficiently at global
scale
[Music]
nihal advani welcome to 20 minute
leaders thank you so much for being here
with me today how are you good how are
you nice to meet you thanks for having
me
i'm really excited to have you here
talking about insights and data-driven
decisions really for anybody you know
our world has become so data-driven
to the point where i'm a little scared
sometimes about how data-driven it is
but but really more excited than scared
i'm excited to hear from you how
different agencies brands and groups
make decisions based on insights that
you help provide them through qualcites
but more importantly i'm excited to hear
about
your
your journey within qualcites and how
and why you're so excited and passionate
about what you do sony hall thank you
for being here and tell me a little bit
about yourself and sort of what what is
qual sites for you
sure so a little bit about myself as i
grew up in india um i actually used to
play tennis for india as a junior uh
that's what actually got me to the us uh
back in the day uh on a college worship
and uh turned into an internship with
google and then a job at microsoft
thereafter once i graduated and that's
sort of what got me really excited about
tech and the media things like that and
then i decided to quit to start my own
thing well i love tennis i have to hear
a little bit about the city you you get
a scholarship to us college and you come
and you play
at college and tennis and then how did
you get in what happened to google how
does that fall into the place where
you're competing professionally it was
it was kind of interesting like my first
business course is actually my junior
year uh with this professor that made
you follow one company he doesn't even
realize the amazing impact that he's had
on my life uh in that time i just
started hear about google uh and i said
oh that's how it seems like an
interesting company let me follow google
and so throughout the course i actually
followed google and it was every week
and you follow a different department
you know finance in hr and this and that
and so i really learned a lot about it
got super exciting passion about google
in particular so i applied there for an
internship and i was fortunate enough to
be one of very few that got selected for
it i guess i was very very well prepared
once i got the call uh that helped uh
and uh yeah that just kind of changed my
my path and i decided when i graduated
to pick my technology passion over my
tennis passion and gopro but gold
professional and and
incredible and so you're in tech and
you're discovering a bunch of things
well what led to
sort of i know that you've also had a
pivot within call size but what what
what led to today's understanding of
what qualcites should be
yeah it was quite the journey honestly
so i started qualified for this company
10 years ago uh quit microsoft started a
travel planning company called georama
uh and so very very different from what
we did today we've had a couple bullets
hooked with along the way uh and
initially of course the passion and the
reason for starting this was you know
travel uh very very passionate travel
you know since my family has been a big
trial family for personally as well and
so it's something that i just want to
help with better travel planning that's
what you know i quit to launch
uh it was really hard though to make
money in the industry especially the
travel planning side because booking was
commoditized and so on and so forth
and so we pivoted to a video uh virtual
travel platform which is a very novel
idea at the time pre-preschool
pre-facebook live and so on uh
meerkat as well um and uh at that point
uh we were doing not just tourism but
also education and campus tours and
anything about live virtual video
helping people go where they couldn't go
it's almost like a reverse play on the
traditional travel
um
it was good but we were kind of trying
to be everything to everybody and so
we decided to kind of focus on one thing
that we could really own and master we
got into 500 startups out of the valley
and that's really a programming news to
kind of find that one vertical and then
ironically after doing research it was
research and insights that was where we
could have the biggest impact so that's
how we made the move and why we're so
passionate about call sites today is
really what we're helping companies with
is uh we're helping them with innovation
a lot of the work we do is around you
know innovation both at you know early
stage prototype stage launch post launch
and so on um and so really being a part
of the toolkit for these big major
brands across a variety of industries
and helping them build better products
through deeper insights is why it's very
very exciting uh for us
fantastic so tell me about insights and
data-driven decisions today what what
are some of the most meaningful insights
that that could support a and a brand to
make decisions and and then how does
qualtrics and you fit into this
understanding
yeah absolutely so if you think of like
data as you mentioned right there's a
lot of data almost too much data out
there there's not enough actual insight
and a lot of that data is all based on
kind of automated data really what we're
talking about here is and also digital
data we focus a lot on offline consumer
behavior data so how people cook or
clean or shop or eat when while we do
that qualitatively rather than surveys
right surveys are great because they're
fast they're scalable but they lack that
depth and context qualitative research
on the other hand talking to consumers
gives you that depth and context but
traditionally lacks speed and
scalability what we've built though is a
way to kind of capture that in a much
more natural and better and also
scalable way so rather than bringing
people let's say to a focus rule
facility which was you know the way
things was done until you speak over it
uh what we've been focused on is
allowing people to remotely connect with
consumers while they're in their home
using our app on their phone they
download the app and they be a part of
selling of course paid to give their
feedback but this way they're doing
things as they do so for example the
next time they go to a store physical
retail store they're able to go there
and actually capture that moment and
show how they're shopping for a
particular category if that's the study
that they were accepted into similarly
in home we'll send them products you
know some prototypes and other things
that they'll be able to test and do in
our research test but actually see them
use product rather than asking them how
they used it you know three four five
days later so it's all about being in
the moment and see as it happens and
then of course because it's video and
audio and unstructured data we have a
whole suite of ai tools that helps
analyze that data much faster
got it got it okay so if so so a lot of
companies in the space are looking at
you know the average consumer and trying
to gain insights from how the average
consumer experiences their product on
the shelf through maybe computer vision
or through sensors or back at home
through just immediately
adding a you know sending back some
feedback but you're actually saying
let's do some dedicated studies pick
some specific customers and then create
dedicated data through their own
experience right exactly and really
answering the why because even if you
think of either the cameras in the store
there's a lot of water data okay for
traffic there okay how long they still
have that why did they spend so were
they confused or they interested in the
products we have no idea so asking the
consumer actually having the voice of
the consumer while they're in a store or
while they're in a home
not just let you observe them but also
let you understand their thought
behavior because they're underrated as
they speak because they're unboxing or
they're cooking or cleaning they're kind
of talking about their experience and
they feel get a blend of observing and
talking and sometimes those don't match
right it could be interesting that
sometimes people think they're doing
something a certain way but when you see
it it's actually very different but it's
great to have both those those data
points and then be able to make much
more sense
tell me a little bit about the
uh consumer behavior for people that are
enrolling in studies you know one of the
things that i've
that i've always noticed and at least in
academia it's you know it's one thing to
enroll somebody in the study it's
another thing to get them to actually
follow through with accurate data and
accurate
and accurate behavior so how do you sort
of think through that a problem or or is
it even a problem maybe it's not
no so it's you know it's something we
definitely think a lot about and it's
something where you know on the
quantitative side there's a lot of
challenges with things like you know
fraud and survey box and things like
that in quality of the good thing
especially with video based quality like
us uh you see the person so you know
they are who they say they are right now
of course in terms of follow through uh
what we've done in our platform age
source will make it super simple make
our app super simple and easy and kind
of easy to follow through but beyond
that actually have a whole bunch of
automated reminders and different things
that automatically not sure rather than
any kind of manual process to kind of
keep requesting the data everything is
automated including the activities and
tasks that they're required to do are
requested to do um the order of which
the date of time that you know it bumps
up and push notification all those
things if they haven't completed within
the server time they get a couple of
reminders and a certain cadence so that
allows us to ensure that that completion
rate is very high
fantastic so maybe what would be helpful
is also to understand a little bit from
the brand's perspective what are some
maybe case studies or whatever you can
share of course of where you know these
insights
made an impact on it on a on a decision
that a brand was making or potentially
make
yeah absolutely there's so many you know
i can give you one high level example um
is if you think of you know there's
basically a big uh you know uh
anti-driver brand uh that we're working
with as an example and uh they were
looking to launch uh essentially
uh a new innovation on new innovations
around uh differentiating between heavy
dandruff sufferers and light that their
sufferers of course previously they just
had one product that kind of catered to
all and so they came to us to be able to
kind of understand those two different
groups we recruited consumers that you
know were part of those future groups
across you know different you know uh
geographies and demographics and things
like that and they were asked for a
period of seven days to record
themselves and anytime they had a flare
up uh we had activities around you know
basically their routines right before
shower what products that they had in
the home a whole bunch of different
activities that kind of got them to
deeply understand both those unique
groups and why they were different and
then actually send them concepts this
was digital concepts because it was more
early stage idea at the time and show
them those concepts and have them react
to that concept the packaging the
messaging and so on and then be able to
iterate you know after a couple
different times and so that in that one
single project they were able to
understand those groups it rained on
their concepts and then kind of have a
much more confident watch there
fantastic and so
within qualcites are you looking to be
more of a of a generalist approach where
you're helping organizations because
obviously this is relevant for any
organization right any brand any agency
and and i'm guessing is
if it a prerequisite to that question is
this
is this more physical is this can also
this also be used for digital products
for things that people do under you know
just on their mobile phones yeah we do
have some screen capture capabilities so
they can be done for digital but a lot
of work that we do is around offline and
when digital comes in it's usually a
combination of offline and digital um
right we do some digital only work but
that's a smaller part of the business
because there's a lot of other companies
doing digital focus stuff we focus much
more on the white space around you know
offline consumer behavior yeah i mean
that makes sense they're they're that i
mean it
definitely the the big blind spots are
on the physical spaces and so there how
are you thinking strategically about
growth so for you know
few clients that are very high priority
versus a long tail of clients that are
smaller and almost sort of a self-serve
type of mechanism where which which
place are you more interested in being
we started mobile the fortune 500s to
begin with so we started with big big
customers um and we worked with a whole
bunch of different uh cbg brands for
example some of the world's largest cbg
companies uh some of them actually work
with us um and across you know within
cbg of course household goods food and
beverage beauty and so on uh for wine
and spreads etc uh we also work with
pharma tech and retail and so we've kind
of gone after like the major customers
first and then yes we do have a long
tail strategy to kind of have pure diy
kind of approach for the long tail uh
which is something that we'll be kind of
focusing more on you know in the coming
what months but uh for now we started um
with big guys
fantastic tell me a little bit about
your perspective today about about
insights and the
data-driven decisions and sort of as you
see it now so you know you've you've
seen a lot of examples you've been
building out these products where are we
headed to
as a world or as a you know from also
from product developers perspective
absolutely yeah there's there's some
very we had a pivotal kind of time right
so covert of course accelerated a whole
bunch of things within our industry
especially when it comes to kind of
doing things remotely and digitally even
if it was around physical data capture
right so in traditionally at least in
the quality of silence fence things were
done a lot in person many getting people
to a central location whether it be for
food tests whether it be for focus
groups or interviews now all of that can
be done remotely and of course they're
forced to be on remotely for a couple
years and so people got a taste of that
even the companies that were legacy or
more older school in their thinking and
not necessarily willing to try that had
to try that and then decided wow this is
actually really cool and it's you know
cheaper faster easier more uh you know
you can get larger geographies and so on
and so forth um and so that's here to
stay so that's one kind of big change
that's happened that's then accelerate
companies like ours and technologies
like ours that help with kind of doing
that but beyond that the holy grail of
research has always been how do you
passively uh understand consumer
behavior without it being kind of active
right without it being kind of without
them being kind of more conscious about
it and that's why we have it's still in
self something so i can't really talk
about it but we have some very exciting
innovations that we're going to be
launching later this year uh officially
they're already kind of being used by a
couple of our biggest customers uh but
it's something around really passively
and autonomously capturing that behavior
without um the consumer having to kind
of you know actively kind of capture
video for example uh and doing that is
really going to change the game in terms
of the kinds of insights that are
unlocked
but from the
you know businesses perspectives
and
are they
do you re did do you see a rise of
consciousness i guess or understanding
about the importance of these
data-driven decisions i'm sort of asking
about you know the generational shifts
for
for brands and agencies that are
creating these products is is there a
shift of understanding about what's even
possible to do
i think so yeah absolutely absolutely
and again uh i think not only right
there people have you know big data has
been around for a while there's a lot of
what data that's the issue i think is
there's a lot of what data there's not
enough why data we are focused on the
why part of that data right and so
that's really where we think there is
you know in the past years ago when you
did qualitative type of work you're
doing it at very small scale so you're
kind of getting quick feedback from a
few sets a few consumers and then you're
really using survey-based mechanisms to
kind of get those you know larger like
validated insights with a large group of
people but now thanks to technology now
ai can really help you know understand
and distill you know unstructured data
much faster and easier that's gonna
really allow you to get and have
conversations at scale have you know
observational behavior kind of collected
and analyzed at scale and those kinds of
insights get much more depth and
therefore there's much more insight that
you're getting out of it versus a
closed-ended survey that only gives you
that much depth you know it gives you a
lot of scale and you know uh validation
but doesn't give you enough depth and
that's why you know if you think about
the
launch that is it's introducing
depending on the source you go to it's
anywhere between 45 to 85
of cvg new cbg products fail
um and we believe the reason for that is
today the way they do it is very much
just survey-based concept based they're
not doing enough of usage tests for
stuff and they're also not doing enough
of that why an observation they're doing
much more conceptual survey based okay
people love this it should be successful
and really that is not enough at all and
so giving them both those sides of the
fence at scale is what we believe is
going to change those figures and allow
much more successful uh
perks
and do you expect that over that over
time there will be a shift in in sort of
the understanding of the motivation
the willingness to adopt these solutions
and to absolutely interact with it there
already has been i think uh you know
again covert accelerated some of that
because they were kind of forced to kind
of use digital tools then as they use
those they're like oh wow there's some
very interesting things that i hear you
know yeah like not every company was
exposed to the the you know power of ai
in the inside soil and now many of them
are getting that and so the
understanding the power of you know
observational techniques and ai and they
you know well on their way of course you
know there's always these leaders in the
industry that kind of start first and
kind of you know other ones to kind of
follow but uh i think the industry in
general has now been accelerated i think
you know several years faster than it
would have otherwise and that's exciting
it's going to continue to because now
with them already hooked onto these
digital platforms that are innovating um
you know as included that allows them to
kind of really stay in the game and
there's been a lot of willingness for
them to try these methods because
everyone is looking for deeper insights
especially when you think of these macro
economic issues right so you know
whether it be of course governor one
point you know inflation now all these
things sustainability these different
themes always kind of make it very very
important to see how consumer behavior
is changing uh across you know uh these
environments
right so i think you know even going a
little bit higher level i'm i'm
wondering
who will be the more proactive one so
obviously as as technology is evolving
and as as ai is allowing us to to get
deeper insights and to to try out
different things in the real world that
previously were not really relevant i'm
wondering whether these brands and
agencies will ever be the ones to know
what to even ask for right i mean it's
one thing to know in general yeah we
want to be more data driven so we want
to employ ai to do so but i'm wondering
whether they'll actually be able to
to request these k the specific
capabilities for their own product so
they're all or they will always need a
company like call sites to come in and
advise them on a case by case basis as
to what exact experiments they should be
running to be to get more structured
data for these insights you know it's
already a combination of both so since
we are you know a tech platform it's
something that we have basically you
know we've made it such that they can
come and they can use it very very much
themselves so we don't really need to
provide much consultation we do of
course help you know with designing
things especially with the new client
who hasn't kind of worked with these
kinds of methodologies before so we can
guide them but there are many clients
already that you know kind of know how
to get the best value out of this and
clients also that are forward thinking
that say hey do you have this or do you
have that and sometimes you do sometimes
you don't when we don't we listen very
closely because then we know okay this
is what the market's asking for and
we're constantly building we're pushing
new product out every week twice a week
actually so it's something that you know
we're always staying ahead of the game
listening to our customers and what they
want especially the ones that are headed
again and then of course for those that
are kind of just you know more older
school kind of coming into this we of
course uh you have to have a little bit
of a heavier hand uh guiding them but um
you know it's been it's been uh
straightforward to do so far
and how long has it been since the pivot
to what you're doing now so we pivoted
in 2018 into goal sets so uh been three
and a half or so years
so so three and a half years into it i'm
going back to the you know really the
theme here what what is your why today
so why why do you do qual sites why do
you do what do you do
yeah i've always been you know even
better to think of the the the while
it's very different the two businesses
you know from you know the grammar we
call the travel planning days to call
sites uh it was always around the
curiosity around
understanding humans and back then also
places right cultures humans people this
is the same thing it's just instead of
doing it for a tourism or more general
learning it's actually done for building
better brands and i personally am very
very passionate about innovation you
know that's the big like i'm a product
focused kind of ceo and so it's
something that you know being able to
impact other you know companies
innovation is really exciting to me as
well so it's a combination of helping
understand humans and you know obviously
uh human brains and humans in general
are complex uh in you know beings and so
being helping understand and unlock that
but also helping with innovation now
both those things that are what would
drive me into this and kind of make very
day energized
phenomenal nihal thank you very much
this was really really great i loved
hearing about you know qual sites and
about data driven decisions in the
physical world versus the digital world
and a little bit about your why as well
so thank you very much best of luck with
call sites i look forward to following
the journey and uh best of luck thanks
so much